have you ever wondered what career
opportunities a software engineer has
there are several career paths most
developers take
the first and obvious one is to grow in
the area in which you are working
if you are a junior developer then grow
to become a middle one then move into a
senior role and finally become a tech
lead
as a second option you can transition to
another technology stack
for example a significant number of
developers moved into the mobile area
when ios and android os gained ground
third you can grow into a managerial
role
there is a shortage of competent
managers out there
smart managers are expensive and they
are scarce
if the manager has a technical
background it will definitely allow him
to better understand his development
team and speak the same language
finally there is another option
you can become a software architect
and this will be the focus of today's
video
before moving forward it is necessary to
define the software architect role and
responsibilities
wikipedia defines this role as following
a software architect is a software
expert who makes high-level design
choices and dictates technical standards
including software coding standards
tools and platforms
like most high-level positions there are
no clear criteria that define this role
however it is possible to identify
several characteristics that contribute
to the career of the architect
the first characteristic of the software
architects is related to their ability
to master both deep and broad technical
knowledge
what this means is that they have
expertise in one or two technological
stacks at an expert level
which we can call deep knowledge
and at the same time have a decent
understanding of a few other ones
which we can call broad knowledge
when a person is good at many things
while specializing in a particular area
they can be viewed as a t-shaped person
a t-shaped person has deep knowledge in
one particular area and a broad base of
general supporting knowledge in multiple
other areas
if you represent this depth and breadth
visually you get a t shape
most software developers that are just
starting out usually find that their
knowledge or skill set looks more like
an eye a specialist with no broad
knowledge
for example a person might become a
javascript expert
some developers however move from one
project to another during the early
stages of their career development
acquiring a lot of diverse knowledge
without specializing in any particular
area
for example they can develop front-end
using html css and javascript on one
project and then move to mobile app
project and learn how to develop iphone
user interfaces
these developers would be considered a
dash shaped person
over time however the top software
developers learn how to combine
effectively both deep and broad
knowledge to become a t-shaped person
next characteristic of the software
architects is that they often assume
high level of responsibility in their
roles you should understand that
architect decisions are usually the most
expensive ones
therefore a person in this position
should take the most responsible
approach to his work and decisions made
if the developers error costs a couple
of days of work of one person
then the architect's mistake can cost
person years on complex projects
software architects have to make tough
decisions on a daily basis simply
because they are expected to do so
they are working with different people
from different areas
and have to deal with rapidly changing
demands or even with changing business
environments on a constant basis
therefore to be an effective software
architect
one has to learn how to make tough
decisions under stress
another important characteristic of the
software architects is the advanced
communication skills
communication is defined as the activity
of conveying information through the
exchange of thoughts and messages by
speech visuals signals writing or
behavior
you see technical background is
important to make technical decisions
but without proper communication it will
not be possible to get the information
necessary for the technical solution and
to sell it to the stakeholders
during the working day software
architects have to speak with customers
in the language of business stakeholders
and managers of all levels business
analysts as well as their development
team members
those who have a natural charisma and
know how to convince people have a huge
advantage in this role
in a nutshell effective software
architects are iconic eloquent and
competent speakers
to sum it up
here are the most important
characteristics of the software
architects
they have developed deep and broad
technical knowledge
they know how to take on responsibility
they are great communicators
it takes much more to be effective in
this role but these are considered the
most important traits that aspiring
software engineers should develop if
they want to become software architects
now let's discuss what software
architects do in their roles
here's the list of key job
responsibilities
identifying the key stakeholders on the
project
identifying business requirements and
requirements of the stakeholders
designing the entire system based on the
receive requirements
choosing the system architecture and
each component of this system
choosing the technologies for the
implementation of each component and
connections between the parts
code review
writing project documentation and
supporting it
creating unified development standards
in the company
this list of responsibilities is only a
subset of the software architect's job
duties the most important responsibility
is full technical support of the project
from the moment of inception
through product release to the
development of all of the consecutive
product features and enhancements
now imagine that you want to become a
software architect
where do you start
how do you achieve this objective
to begin with it is requisite to define
milestone goals that lead to achieving
your strategic objective of becoming a
software architect
these might include the following
milestone one
understand and try several technological
stacks
for example if your current knowledge is
concentrated in the field of ios it is
necessary to try android as well as
several server side languages such as
python or rust
alternatively if your current knowledge
is concentrated in the field of devops
you might want to consider learning
database engineering machine learning
and app security
milestone 2
reading literature
it is required to determine the most
valuable books and articles that will
help to grow in your direction of choice
usually the most effective way to find
such literature is to ask other
professionals in this field for their
recommendation
milestone three
obtain certificates
there are many certifications available
but only a few are worth their money
before starting however make sure that
the lecturer of the course is an
established professional in his field
and can answer your questions
milestone 4
find a mentor
it is desirable to find a software
architect at your current place of
employment
it is always easier to get experience
from a trained specialist than to start
considering a particular area from
scratch
be prepared to ask the right questions
from your mentor
as you move towards your strategic
objective of becoming a software
architect
one of the essential parts is a clear
and continuous plan review
you should always check what has been
done what should be reviewed and where
to accelerate or which goal to remove as
useless
however
even if you do not have a stable plan
available it is better to start taking
small steps that move you ahead rather
than remaining in the same place
know that this path might take several
years
the process of becoming a software
architect does not happen overnight
yet once you become a software architect
you will be able to create a lasting
impact on the organization you will be
employed by
and that's one of the best
accomplishments you might achieve in
life as a software engineer
if you found this video useful i'd
appreciate it if you smash the like
button and click on the notification
bell
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel for more videos like
this in the future